hey everybody it's Mike frieder here
with Hong Kong compliance Solutions and
I'm back with another compliance tip of
the week this week we're talking about
cmmccontrol
ac.l2-3.1.13 employee cryptographic
mechanisms to protect the
confidentiality of remote access
sessions I don't know maybe they use
some cryptography to come up with these
control numbers because they sure are
complicated let's get into it
[Music]
so hey if you're a defense contractor
who's feeling overwhelmed tired and
alone trying to understand all of this
cmmc dfars and nist sp-800 171 compliant
stuff on top of an already colossal
workload well I've got some great news
for you you've found your home here at
on-call compliance Solutions where we
can help you transform into your
company's on-call compliance hero so in
cmmc control AC dot
l2-3.1.13 I feel like I could wrap that
employ cry cryptographic mechanisms to
protect the confidentiality remotes
access sessions what we are doing is
making sure that any kind of remote
access session is protected from attacks
like packet sniffing attacks okay if
you're not familiar with what that means
there are programs out there that can
essentially listen to Network traffic
and put it back together and decode it
just by being on the same network as you
are what can be sniffed in that session
well when if traffic isn't encrypted
basically anything if it's encrypted
you're good to go usually obviously
that's not acceptable when we were
talking about defense related
information in cui and of course
passwords into your system none of which
should be set via clear text they should
all be encrypted now if I'm an assessor
there are two assessment points on this
control that I'm looking for number one
I'm looking to determine if
cryptographic mechanisms to protect the
confidentiality of remote access
sessions are identified so again have I
identified what kind of encryption is in
play here if I was going to give an
example we'll throw out an example like
this cryptographic mechanisms include
256-bit AES fips 140-2 compliant
encryption required on the VPN
connection right because that's where
we're going to protect it is the VPN
connection defining and documenting
right
now second assessment Point determine if
cryptographic mechanisms to protect the
confidentiality of remote access
sessions are implemented and of course
simplest answer is well yes of course
they are they're implemented via the
firewall settings and you can just log
in the firewall settings do a little
shoulder surfing a little screen sharing
a little
show and tell and see that it's
implemented right there in the settings
now and on call we work with defense
contractors just like you who have had
this defars nist itar and cmmc
compliance stuff dropped in their laps
like a seal on a sunny day baby and we
teach you how to level up and be a
proper on-call compliance hero for your
company eliminating gaps great areas and
getting this solved all while showing
you how to leverage compliance as your
secret weapon to land more Defense work
with higher profit margins that's what I
get excited about I hope you do too
that's what becoming an on-call
compliance here on working with us can
do for you if you're looking for more
help getting compliant our compliance
experts are always on call for you visit
cmmccompliance secrets.com or check out
the bio below for links to get help
right now
just do it right now just like scroll
down right hit the little down arrow
thing there and there's our link you can
click that and you're like one step
closer to getting help if you love the
content we're putting out here for you
help us out with a big thumbs up on that
like button or even better smash the
Subscribe button to get the latest
compliance content as soon as our
compliances roll it out until next
compliance tip my friends stay safe and
secure out there hit us in the comments
below to let us know what you'd like to
know more about when it comes to
information security and compliance and
I'll see you on the next one
thank you
foreign
[Music]